[Música]
[Aplausos]
y ustedes saben que en nuestro cuerpo se
alojan 2500 veces la población de
habitantes que se encuentran en el
planeta tierra
son alrededor de 100 billones de
microorganismos dentro de los cuales
contamos con virus y virus bacterias
parásitos hongos y levaduras y que el
85% de estos microorganismos se alojan
en nuestro intestino grueso resulta que
si nosotros seleccionamos todos esos
microorganismos su peso aproximado va
desde 200 hasta 800 gramos
su peso aproximado va desde los 200
hasta los 800 gramos y se conoce como
microbiota intestinal les cuento algo no
le digan flora intestinal está obsoleto
y pasado de moda es casi también exacto
como decir que eeuu es américa
entonces nuestro micro nuestra
microbiota intestinal cumple diversas
funciones que son vitales para el buen
funcionamiento de nuestro organismo una
de ellas es contar con un excelente
salud digestiva nos ayuda a absorber
nutrientes sintetiza y produce vitaminas
como por ejemplo la vitamina k que sin
esta vitamina el proceso de coagulación
de la sangre no podría realizarse
además
fue forma un escudo protector para
nuestro sistema inmunológico y se
mantienen en estado de alerta ante la
llegada de algún patógeno que nos pueda
causar daño
una de las de los procesos más
impresionantes y que para mí un bolo mi
cabeza es que hay una conexión directa
entre nuestro intestino grueso
y nuestro cerebro ustedes saben que en
nuestro intestino grueso se produce el
90% de la serotonina y la dopamina que
son las hormonas de la felicidad
no sé si ustedes les pasa pero al menos
a mí cuando consuma alimentos me generan
emociones
una cosa diferente
es cuando consumo alimentos de muy buena
calidad me siento feliz
me siento feliz me siento con energía y
otra cosa diferente es cuando estoy bajo
mucho estrés paso mucho tiempo sin comer
y ahí me siento súper enojada incluso
quienes me conocen pueden dar fe de que
cuando tengo hambre soy furiosa así que
en este caso les recomiendo no conocerme
cuando microorganismos tienen hambre
y bueno resulta que después de que
nuestros microorganismos realizan esa
cantidad de procesos vitales para
nuestro organismo necesitan alimento al
igual que nuestras células humanas y
bueno a partir de qué alimentos vamos a
nutrir nuestra microbiota intestinal y
microbiota humana resulta que desde que
nacemos empezamos a nutrir a equilibrar
y a proteger nuestra microbiota
intestinal a partir de la leche materna
la leche materna es el mejor alimento
que le podemos brindar a nuestros
microorganismos en los primeros meses de
vida
luego cuando dejamos de consumir leche
materna
qué alimentos vamos a consumir para
mantener en equilibrio este gran
ecosistema
según el estudio realizado por la
asociación internacional de prebióticos
y probióticos y publicado en la revista
'nature' en 2018 nos brindan dos grandes
grupos de alimentos
qué son los alimentos prebióticos que se
encuentran en vegetales frescos frutas
frescas
vegetales frescos frutas frescas
germinados granos y semillas
ojalá que provengan de suelos orgánicos
y que van a contener un contenido de
fibra que la conoceremos como fibra
prebiótica
que se van a obtener almidones
resistentes y además
fructooligosacáridos que la idea es que
estas fibras pasen directamente por todo
el proceso digestivo y que lleguen
intactas a nuestro intestino donde va a
ser un gran gran gran banquete para
nuestros habitantes microscópicos aquí
me encantaría hacer un gran paréntesis
abrir un gran paréntesis porque porque
bueno un sector de la industria de
alimentos nos ha hecho creer y nos ha
hecho pensar
que todos los alimentos provienen en
cajitas y bolsitas muy coloridas
muy coloridas con una cantidad de una
lista enorme de ingredientes
dentro de los cuales la gran mayoría no
podemos pronunciar y muchísimo menos
saber que son resulta que esas listas
enormes de ingredientes están
abarrotadas de colorantes artificiales
saborizantes artificiales
harinas y azúcares refinadas y en serio
aquí como el chacal el más detestable de
todos el jarabe de maíz de alta fructosa
y edulcorantes artificiales
este conjunto de aditivos son el peor
alimento que le podemos brindar a
nuestros microorganismos
y bueno nos vamos a otro grupo de
alimentos que realmente sí enriquecen
nuestra microbiota y lo disfruta
muchísimo estos son los alimentos
probióticos que no son más que alimentos
que se someten a procesos de
fermentación y que generan
microorganismos buenos para nuestra
salud
resulta que aquí quiero hacer dos
aclaraciones muy muy muy importantes una
de ellas es que el yoghurt no es el
único alimento con microorganismos
probióticos que podemos consumir a
diario
y además
los alimentos fermentados son deliciosos
y aclaro aquí muy bien como me han
preguntado múltiples veces los alimentos
fermentados no son alimentos podridos
de hecho si ustedes observan los
alimentos que consumen a diario
una gran mayoría pasa por procesos de
fermentación
y requieren de microorganismos para
poder producirse como cual es bueno las
levaduras que fermentan un buen pan de
masa madre
además levaduras que fermentan las
birras y los vinos que nos tomamos los
fines de semana bueno cuando podíamos
salir a bares y a fiestas
también bacterias que fermentan la leche
para producir un buen queso madurado
nuestros granos como por ejemplo el café
y el cacao
y cuando nosotros nos damos cuenta
que debemos de nutrir no solo nuestras
células humanas sino que tenemos que
nutrir nuestra microbiota intestinal y
humana realmente vemos cambios en
nuestra salud por ejemplo en mi caso
deje de contar con digestiones pesadas
hay ataques de ansiedad depresión etc
y aquí le quiero les quiero brindar dos
tips que aplicó hace más de seis años en
mi vida y uno de ellos es consuma
vegetales frescos verduras frescas
granos y semillas que contengan
prebióticos número 2 anímese a consumir
a conocer alimentos fermentados entre
mayor diversidad mejor va a ser nuestra
microbiota intestinal y número 3
recuerde que si usted quiere tener
digestiones felices quiere tener un
escudo protector en su sistema
inmunológico y producir hormonas que le
produzcan felicidad debe de alimentar a
más de 100 billones de microorganismos
que nos habitan muchas gracias
[Música]
cómo
canto